enfin les premières projections en
direct du ciné 7 d'elancourt 18 mois de
travaux auront finalement permis signer
cette d'être entièrement rénové le
cinéma dispose désormais d'une troisième
salle
cinquante cinq fauteuils supplémentaires
aux couleurs âme et east en font un
espace confortable et cosy dédiée au
cinéma d'art et d'essai cette nouvelle
salle permettra également d'organiser
des soirées débats et même des
projections privées
les deux autres salles d'origine ont
elles aussi été transformé des écrans
plus larges de nouveaux fauteuils un
accès par l'ascenseur qui dessert ainsi
il trois niveaux le ciné 7 devient plus
accessible et on a aussi voulu rester un
lieu comme on dirige à taille humaine
conviviale accessible
on est aussi accessible jeudi au passage
sur le sera demain matin quand on sera
ouvert aux personnes à mobilité réduite
personnes qui sont en fauteuil aux
personnes qui ont des difficultés
auditives ou de vue véritable cinéma de
proximité
le ciné 7 à tout d'un grand proposer un
lieu qui soit au top en terme de confort
vous voyez la place que j'ai aux jambes
là on a préféré supprimer quelques
fauteuils plutôt que de casser les
jambes
et puis je me confort visuel et sonore
ce n'est pas parce qu'on est une petite
salle pour avoir un son rabais ou une
image au rabais
bien au contraire je pense est donc là
on aura nous ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'on
projection sera en projection casque 4k
et en sont 37 points lens est une norme
aujourd'hui la norme c'est 5 points 37
points donc c'est mieux et on sera entre
et amplification cette salle là et enbil
amplification les deux autres salles
donc on devrait les gens devraient très
content je pense au noir ce qui se fait
de mieux en terme de confort qualité de
son et d'image avec une politique
tarifaire inchangé 6 euros le billet
plein tarif
l'ouverture est prévue le 3 avril